The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Time to learn.
Time to get back to business
here in 3.091.
So let's do the announcements
first. Tomorrow quiz one,
based on homework one.
Ten minutes.
Bring your Periodic Table,
your table of constants,
something to write with
and a calculator.
There's about a dozen or so
copies of the text on reserve
at the Hayden Library.
I want you to be
aware of that.
Now some of you approached me
last day and said is it true
that we have to memorize
the Periodic Table?
Yes.
But not the whole
Periodic Table.
I know some of you are going
to say, well that's so 19th
century, rote learning
and so on.
To which I say, you're wrong.
Every educated person should
know that potassium lies under
sodium, which lies
under lithium.
And you are going to
be educated whether
you like it or not.
But this is a lot to learn and
so we're just going to look at
the main block.
We're not going to ask you to
memorize the lanthanides,
actinides and the
super heavies.
We'll leave that out.
So it's quite straightforward.
We've been doing this
for many years.
This is from 2004.
And it's not that hard.
I give you the blank here.
And I even put the numbers
on for you.
And all you have to do
is add the two-letter
or one-letter symbol.
You don't have to give me the
full name of the element.
You don't have to get
me its density or
its electron affinity.
You've just got to put
argon, in there.
Ar.
That's all you've got
to put in there.
OK?
And every year people grouse
when I announce this.
But you'll find out that you'll
breeze through it.
You'll have 10 minutes.
This will be on September 24.
So next week there will be
two minor celebrations.
One on Tuesday and
one on Thursday.
So it's going to be a
very festive week.
And people blast through it.
It's one mark off for every
error down to zero.
We don't give negative scores.
And people just go
right through it.
And then they urge me
to make sure that in
future years I victimi--
I mean I ask students
to continue this.
People are very proud of the
fact they know the S, P, and D
blocks of the Periodic
Table by memory.
But I don't want to neglect,
disrespect the
lanthanides and actinides.
So we're going to have
two contests.
Mnemonics to help remember
the names of the
lanthanides and actinides.
That's tricky to remember.
So these are mnemonics
contests.
So here are some examples.
Here's one, see lanthanum,
cerium, praseodymium,
neodymium and so
on, all right?
Obviously this one came from
industry because of the slur
against the Academy.
Obviously, somebody in industry
has no idea how hard
we work here.
And plus, look at this: "to
dramatically help".
This gigantic split
infinitive.
Clearly, clearly someone
from industry.
Here's another one that would
help you memorize, I think.
Now, this is obviously not
referring to 3.091.
It must be referring
to some other
chemistry professor here.
I'll let that go unchallenged.
Now, occasionally people
ratchet up.
And this was about six, seven
years ago, a young man by the
name of Blake Stacey, who was
aware of the fact that there
are 14 lanthanide elements
because there
are fourteen F electrons.
And an Elizabethan sonnet
has 14 lines.
And so he took Sonnet 57 by
Shakespeare in reference to
the fact that lanthanum
is element 57.
And he wrote this in reference
to Sonnet 57.
And, of course, he knew he was
going to win when he made
samarium the word smelting,
and being the chemical
metallurgist I am, he had
me at the fifth line.
Actually, I showed this to
Professor Sonenberg in
Humanities, and she said,
actually, this is pretty good.
That's one of those times you
look at and say, you wouldn't
see this at Harvard.
So now I'm going to
show you one.
Sometimes people ratchet up.
A couple of years ago,
there was a video.
So let's take a look
at that one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And she goes through
various poses as a
superhero of different
elemental value.
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: But we don't
have that much time.
So anyways, September
25, 5:00 p.m.
Eastern Daylight Time.
Submit your entry, whether it's
the big canisters of the
Hollywood footage or
whether it's just a
14-line mnemonic device.
And the prizes--
it's a contest, there
are prizes--
I have ties and scarves from the
American Chemical Society.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: What are
you laughing at?
These things!
Now look at me!
This is going to be stylish.
They're black.
They've got elements from the
Periodic Table on them.
Very hot.
They're black.
They look great.
And we're going to present
them on the Friday of the
parents' weekend because the
parents eat this stuff up.
So now I think it's time to
get back to learning.
So last day we ended with the
stoichiometry, and I showed
you the Kroll process,
how to make titanium.
So the question that we never
got to was how do we tell that
magnesium has a higher affinity
for chlorine than
titanium does?
How do we know that magnesium
is going to reduce titanium
tetrachloride to a sponge?
So for that we have to
look inside the atom.
We have to look inside
the atom.
So that's what we're going
to start doing today.
And we're going to begin,
as often we will,
with a history lesson.
So let's go back for a status
report around the end of the
19th century.
So what did we know towards the
end of the 19th century?
The atom is electrically
neutral.
The negative charge is
carried by electrons.
We knew that there was some
carrier of negative charge.
We knew further that this
electron is very, very tiny.
Small mass.
And so if it has a very small
mass, then by difference, then
the bulk of the mass of atom
must be contained in the
positive charge.
So now the question is, what is
the spatial distribution of
charge inside an atom?
You might say, well why do
we want to know that?
Well, we're trying to get a
physical model of the atom so
that then we can start to
address the question of
chemical reactivity.
So we have got to know where all
the players are before we
can attribute action to them.
So let's now take a look
at models of the atom.
For the first modern model
of the atom we go to J.
J.
Thompson.
Thompson, he was a professor of
physics and director of the
Cavendish lab at Cambridge
University.
The other Cambridge.
Cambridge University.
And this Cavendish Lab was named
after Henry Cavendish.
The same one who is credited
with the discovery
of hydrogen in 1766.
He never married, and when he
died he bequeathed this
fortune to Cambridge University,
and they took that
money and established a physics
laboratory, which is
still in operation
to this day.
So what did J.
J.
Thompson tell us?
He said the electrons were
distributed throughout a
uniformly charged positive
sphere of atomic dimensions.
So that's the text.
Now let's make this cartoon,
because that makes more sense.
Visualize it a little
bit better.
So it looks a little
bit like this.
So here's a sphere of
atomic dimension.
Electrons are these tiny little
things distributed
throughout the positive
sphere.
And this is massive because
the electrons have
very, very low mass.
And just to be clear, there
are no protons.
No protons.
So this isn't positive.
It's a positive chargeness.
It's just a big positive blur.
And then the little
electrons inside.
So the electrons are negative,
and they're tiny and low-mass,
and they're mobile.
He didn't say much about how
they move, but you can imagine
that they move, and maybe
they even spin.
And so on.
And this was known as the
Plum Pudding Model.
There's a big cultural
bias here.
So even though I grew up in
British Canada, I never had
this stuff.
But my understanding is plum
pudding is this dish that's
served at holidays and
Christmas-time.
So the custard is the charge,
the positive charge.
And these little bits of fruit
are the electrons.
And they're throughout.
At Christmas-time, they
might even put
little charms in here.
Like a little wishbone or
something for good luck.
And you pull it out and all
that kind of stuff.
Yeah that's merry,
old England.
So this is the Plum
Pudding Model.
And that's what was in place.
By the way, we've been using
the term electron, but J.
J.
did not like the
term electron.
Actually, he won his Nobel
Prize for the-- quote,
unquote-- the discovery
of the electron.
Just as Cavendish didn't
discover hydrogen, he
characterized it.
J.
Thompson characterized
the electron.
What did he in particular
characterize?
He characterized the
charge-to-mass ratio.
He made the first quantitative
measure of the charge-to-mass
ratio of the electron.
But he never used the
term, electron.
He called it the corpuscle.
He called it the corpuscle of
electrical charge, whereas
this is really sort of
an elementary charge.
The corpuscle.
And fortunately there was
another British chemist. In
fact, he was an electrochemist.
His name was
John Stoney, who, while I think
that Thompson was a
brilliant man, I wasn't crazy
about his literary choices.
And it was Stoney who said,
let's call the term electron,
coming from the Greek term,
elektra, which is the Greek
word for amber.
And you know if you rub amber,
you'll build up static
charge, and so on.
That's where we got
the electron from.
So that looks pretty good.
So that's our theory.
And what happens next?
Well, what happens next is that
we've got to put this
theory to the test. And the
person who puts the theory to
the test is a man by the name
of Ernest Rutherford.
Rutherford was an interesting
character.
He came from New Zealand and
he was born on a farm.
It was a family with
12 children.
You notice Mendeleyev came from
a family of 14, this guy
comes from a family of 12.
So you learn how to survive.
He worked on a farm so he was
very handy, and that came in
to play as his career
progressed.
He was a brilliant
experimentalist. He was able
to do experiments where
others failed.
And he did this experiment where
he was a professor of
physics at Victoria University
in Manchester in the UK.
Now, he came out of New Zealand,
got a scholarship to
study at Cambridge University.
And he was actually a research
student for J.
J.
Thompson.
And he conducted his thesis
research under J.
J.
and during that time his thesis
research was about the
properties of charged
particles.
And they were very interested
in gases and radioactive
elements, ionizing radiation,
the whole thing.
The Cavendish lab was a
beehive of activity.
And what he did under his PhD
was he understood both the
alpha particle and the
beta particle.
First, he identified
what they are.
The alpha particle
was determined to
be the helium nucleus.
So this is helium that's lost
both of its electrons.
So it's just protons and
neutrons in the nucleus.
Completely naked.
No electrons.
And then the beta particle,
which other people in physics
had been referring to this
mysterious beta particle, he
made the connection
between the beta
particle and the electron.
So the same electron that's over
here and attributed to
the negative charge within the
nucleus is also a free
particle that can go
through space.
And these are taken
from your reading.
And you can see that if you send
the particle beam through
a charged plate, the negative
plate here being the lower
plate, the positive particle,
which in this case is the
alpha particle, will bend down
towards the negative plate.
And the negative particle, being
the free electron, is
bent in the opposite
direction.
So these are the kinds of
experiments they would do.
And they also looked
at their ability to
penetrate different media.
So when it comes to their
ability to penetrate solids,
they differentiate themselves.
So they alpha particle
is quite poor
at penetrating solids.
So you see in the cartoon there,
the alpha particle is
stopped even by that little
sheet of paper.
So it doesn't do so well here,
whereas the beta particle, the
electron, can go zooming right
through the paper and is
stopped by the lead.
And then over here they were
also studying their ability to
ionize gases.
So if you take a gas and you
bombard it with alpha
particles, will you get
a lot of ionization?
Yes or no, et cetera.
And what they found was that it
was a complementary, that
the alpha particle is pretty
good at ionizing gases,
whereas the beta particle is
poor at ionizing gases, and in
fact, is stopped.
This is why, if you
have an electron
beam you need a vacuum.
Otherwise, the electron will
be dissipated in very, very
short order.
So after doing this
work with J.
J., he got a teaching job
in Canada at McGill
University up north.
And while he was there he
continued to do work on the
origin of alpha particles and
won the Nobel Prize for his
work while he was at McGill.
And so when he determined that
the alpha particle origin in
the decomposition, the
disintegration of elements.
And believe it or not, in this
work back in 1906, 1907, he
was already anticipating nuclear
fission because he was
saying that if you put thorium
or polonium into a tube, you
can expect that it will
emit alpha particles.
Well, conservation of mass
says they have got to be
coming from somewhere.
And if they're not coming from
out here, they have got to be
coming from inside.
This was brilliant work.
This is Rutherford, young man
in Montreal, gets the Nobel
Prize in 1908.
And then he goes to Victoria
University, and he sets up
this experiment.
Critical experiment.
I mean, imagine this guy.
I mean, he's already got
the Nobel Prize.
He could just put his feet up.
No, he keeps going.
So this is the experiment.
It's called the
Rutherford-Geiger-Marsden
experiment.
Because Rutherford was the
brains behind it and Geiger
and Marsden were the
guys in the lab.
And so here's the experiment.
So what he's going to do is he's
going to put this model
to the test. We're going
to see if this model
makes sense or not.
So he's got a gold foil-- now
they used different elements,
but ultimately they loved gold
because gold, first of all, is
noble and it doesn't oxide.
So it's pure, even in
atmospheric oxygen.
And secondly, we've known
since antiquity we can
physically deform gold and
make it into something
sub-paper thin.
So that's what they did.
They beat this thing
down to 600
nanometers thick, 0.6 micron.
And they used alpha
particles here.
Radium, polonium, thorium as
the source in the lead
container and so on.
And this stream of alpha
particles comes zooming out at
energies of 7.68 million
electron volts per particle.
So this is like a cannon with
a pumpkin in front of it.
And they're going to shoot
these at the foil.
So what's the purpose here?
They want to see what's
going on.
And if you imagine that we are
shooting alpha particles,
which are positive, and I've
got a wall here of all of
these nuclei that are
essentially positive
chargeness, uniformly
distributed with these tiny,
tiny little electrons of almost
no mass, you'd expect
that most of these particles are
just going to go zooming
on through.
Beyond a certain thickness,
I might start seeing some
attenuation.
But if I get the gold film
really thin, I should just go
blasting these all through.
Well, what they find
is, two things.
First of all, most of the
particles do go through.
When they go through, they're
deflected a little bit.
They don't just go through,
they are deflected.
And most of them are deflected
through low angles.
But a small number of them are
deflected through high angles.
They almost go straight
back at the source.
So if you've got that set of
data, that doesn't support
this model.
This model cannot be sustained
in the light of those data.
It's a very important
experiment.
By the way, how do they
count these things?
Well, Geiger is the
same guy who give
us the Geiger counter.
Geiger was a technician that
worked for Rutherford.
And he developed this screen,
they called it a
scintillation screen.
It was coated with
zinc sulfide.
And so when alpha particles
bounced and they hit the
screen, they would excite
electrons in the screen and
then cause a scintilla,
a spark.
And then what you do is you just
get a graduate student or
some other source of abundant,
cheap labor-- and you have a
whole bunch of graduate students
sitting here-- and
they count.
That's how it was done in
good old days, 1909.
And so they counted what
the distribution was.
So that's the experiment.
So this is taken
from your book.
So this what you'd expect.
And this is what they saw.
So this is small angles and
this is large angles.
Theaters of the angle here.
Now Marsden, who's the third?
There's a third person.
Marsden.
Marsden's not too different
from you.
Marsden was about 20 years
old at the time.
He dropped out of school and
then he came to Rutherford,
and he said, I'm looking
for a job.
In those days, you couldn't
return to college.
If you dropped out, finished.
You had to stay all
the way through.
Once you dropped out, they
slam the door behind you.
But Rutherford, he
was different.
He looked at people
on the basis of
their intrinsic value.
He didn't care about title.
And so he said to Marsden,
OK, you want to do
something for me?
Here's your question, I like you
to imagine an alternative
model of the atom.
And here's the alternative
What Rutherford said was,
suppose instead, if this is
the dimension of the atom,
instead of having positive
charge uniformly distributed,
he said, what if we have
positive charge concentrated at
one point and then out here
we have the negative charge?
So here's the positive charge.
And here's a whole bunch
of negative charge.
And now here's the next one.
And here's the next one.
And so on.
And now we're going to shoot
these helium nuclei.
See what's in between here?
This is a void, taking
from Democritus.
And so now if I shoot the
positive helium nuclei here,
if they get close
to this positive
charge they'll be deflected.
If they don't get close to the
positive charge, they just go
right through.
And once in awhile they get
almost on axis, in which case
they fling back.
This model would be consistent
with the data set I just
showed you.
And then to go further, he says
to Marsden, I'm going to
tell you what the distribution
of high-angle scattering was,
you tell me what is the ratio
between the radius of the
nucleus, where the positive
charge is to the-- excuse me,
I'm showing you the diameter, so
this is the diameter of the
nucleus versus the diameter
of the atom.
What would be the ratio
of the two?
I mean, it's gold, so I know
I got 79 plus here.
And I've got 2 plus.
And I've got a 79 plus.
What would be the size of the
sphere of 79 plus that would
deflect something of 2 plus
through this angle?
So that's Marsden.
It's not bad for a kid that's
been out of school for a
couple of years.
That's his problem.
So he did.
He did the calculation.
He did the calculation and
Marsden figured out that the
radius of the nucleus to the
radius of the atom is on the
order of about 1 to 10,000.
That means most of the
gold foil is void.
Most of the gold foil
is nothing.
And you've got all this
mass, highly dense,
concentrated here.
So this is the Rutherford model,
which was called the
nuclear model.
This was proposed by Rutherford
because it has such
a thing is a nucleus.
He coined the term, nucleus.
So that's a big step forward
from this thing here.
So you'd think that the physics
community would be ecstatic.
That now we've got a model that
squares with the data.
Well, what do you think the
reaction to Rutherford's
announcement was?
Condemnation.
Derision.
People didn't like it.
They laughed at him.
They said, well,
this is crazy.
There's a couple of problems
with this.
So strong negative reaction
to Rutherford's model.
And here the two major
objections that people posed.
First of all, they talked
about nuclear collapse.
They said if you've got a system
of negative particles
revolving around a positive
nucleus, electrostatic forces
are going to cause them to
be drawn to one another.
What's going to keep the
electrons from collapsing into
the nucleus?
That was the first objection.
Coulombic attraction.
Coulombic, electrostatic,
same thing.
If you want to use a man's
name, Coulombic.
If you don't want to use a man's
name, electrostatic.
Coulombic attraction between
plus and minus.
And the second one was, OK,
suppose for some reason we
don't understand that the
electron doesn't collapse, it
stays in orbit, it's still
not going to work.
Because you run out of energy.
If you take a charged particle,
a charged particle
that accelerates consumes
energy.
Acceleration, as you know, can
mean either change in speed or
change in direction.
So if the electron is revolving
at a constant speed,
it has to change direction;
otherwise, it will
fly out of the room.
So changing direction means
acceleration, which means what
keeps the energy in
the electron?
Why doesn't the electron
just run out of
energy and just stop?
Even if you can prevent
it from collapsing,
it will just stop.
So this is the problem
of energy deficit.
Energy deficit.
Well, what powers
the electron?
What powers the accelerating
electron?
So that's a problem.
So now the story continues.
The next chapter is 1912.
Because this is 1911.
In 1912, a young Danish
businessman by the name of
Niels Bohr.
Niels Bohr just finished his PhD
in Copenhagen and he got a
fellowship from the Carlsburg
Brewery Foundation.
Carlsburg Brewery put up
money for science.
So he won a Carlsburg
fellowship.
And he was a young physicist.
And he knew that in the UK
there was a controversy brewing
between the model of
Rutherford and the model of J.
J.
Thompson.
So he says, you know what
I'm going to do?
I've got a year, I got money.
I'm going to spend six
months with J.
J.
Thompson, I'm going to spend
six months with Ernest
Rutherford.
And that's what he did.
So he goes and he spends
six months at the
Cavendish lab with J.
J.
and then he goes up to
Manchester and he spends three
months at Manchester
with Rutherford.
Why didn't he spend
six months?
Because he got a job offer and
he went back to Copenhagen to
start his teaching duties.
And what he did is
he developed a
quantitative model for us.
He developed a quantitative
model.
And that's all part of what I
showed you the other day.
We recognize patterns.
That's what the Rutherford,
Geiger, Marsden
experiment gave us.
The pattern of the distribution
of alpha particle
deflections.
So now we need to develop a
quantitative model that will
explain the observations, and
if it's a really good model,
it will make predictions that,
again, can be tested by
experiment.
So we ratchet back and forth
between experiment, model.
Experiment, model.
So he proposes the model,
not with J.
J., because J.
J., I don't know what
he did there.
This is where he wants
to propose the model.
Quantitative model.
To Rutherford's atom.
Let's take a look at what
we've got there.
Now, big lesson here.
How do you announce a model?
You don't put an ad
in the newspaper.
This is the scientific
literature.
This is not Google.
This is not Wikipedia.
This is a primary source.
This is how science
is communicated.
So this is a journal.
It's called Philosophical
Magazine
and Journal of Science.
It goes all the way
back to the 1600s.
In fact, when I was a freshman
at the University of Toronto
we had copies of Phil
Mag going back all
the way to the 1600s.
And these were not facsimiles,
these were real copies.
And I was in the stacks and I
was reading something by--
I don't know--
Lord Kelvin, you know late
1800s, and I said gee, well,
if I've got Lord Kelvin, then
maybe I can go over here to
the early 1800s and read Humphry
Davy and, gee, if can
keep going, and going and I
pull out a leather-bound
edition of Phil Mag from the
1660s, and I open the book and
there's a paper about gravity
by Isaac Newton.
And that's how science
is communicated.
So I urge you to go
to the library and
read primary sources.
Most of this stuff is
available online.
You can just sit at
your desk and you
can zoom in to history.
So this is Phil Mag and
this is London,
Edinburgh and dublin.
See this is 1913, so Ireland
was not a free state yet.
So Dublin was a British city.
London, Edinburgh, Dublin.
There's a close-up of it.
July 1913, On the Constitution
of Atoms and Molecules by
Niels Bohr, Doctor of
Philosophy, Copenhagen.
And it was communicated by
Professor Ernest Rutherford,
FRS, Fellow of the
Royal Society.
So, let's read.
It's in English.
In order to explain results of
experiments on scattering of
alpha rays by matter, Professor
Rutherford has given
a theory of the structure
of atoms. You
see the dagger here?
Down here, Ernest Rutherford,
Phil Mag, duh-duh-duh-duh.
There's a citation.
See, attribution.
According to this theory, the
atoms consist of a positively
charged nucleus surrounded by
a system of electrons kept
together by attractive forces
from the nucleus.
That's what keeps them from
just fleeing anywhere, and
they don't go in,
but they vwomp.
The total negative charge of the
electrons is equal to the
positive charge of
the nucleus.
Further, the nucleus is assumed
to be the seat of the
essential part of the mass of
the atom and have linear
dimensions exceedingly small
compared with the linear
dimensions of the whole atom.
This is beautifully written.
Clear.
It's textbook quality and it's
written by a man whose native
language isn't even English.
Read the literature.
The number of electrons in
an atom is deduced to be
approximately equal to half
the atomic weight.
Great interest is to be
attributed to this atom model.
You have to know a little
bit about Bohr.
Bohr used this phrase, great
interest. That was his way of
saying, embroiled
in controversy.
If someone said something that
he didn't agree with, instead
of saying, I think that's
nonsense, he say, very
interesting.
Very interesting.
So great interest is to be
attributed to this atom model.
That means people are in pitched
battle on both sides.
For as Rutherford has shown,
the assumption of the
existence of nuclei as those
in question seems to be
necessary in order to account
for the results of experiments
on large-angle scattering
of the alpha rays.
Another footnote: Geiger
and Marsden.
Geiger and Marsden published
their results in this journal.
In an attempt to explain some of
the properties of matter on
the basis of this atom model,
we meet, however, with
difficulties of a serious
nature arising from the
apparent instability of the
system of electrons.
Difficulties purposely avoided
in atom models previously
considered.
For instance, in the one
proposed by Sir J.
J.
Thompson, which is to say, mmm,
you know, it's curious.
You condemn the Rutherford
model because he's got
electrons in motion, which means
they're accelerating in
energy deficit.
But in the Plum Pudding Model,
the electrons are
in motion, and J.
J.
Thompson is silent about it.
So this is a very aimed
barb right at J.
J.
Thompson done elegantly.
With this elegant slap
in the face.
You know this is how
scientists do it.
They don't go, oh you're
ugly , and your
mother dresses you funny.
Instead they write things like
this, difficulties purposely
avoided in atom models
previously
considered for instance.
So this is sort of yeah,
how about you, huh?
But anyway, we can
go on and on.
But down here, the result of
the discussion of these
questions seems to be a general
acknowledgment of the
inadequacy of classical
electrodynamics in describing
the behavior of systems
of atomic size.
So he's saying that you can't
use classical electrodynamics
down to subatomic dimensions.
He's saying that those models,
any more than you can use
planetary models down to human
dimensions, this, in many
respects, is foretelling
nanotechnology.
He's saying the properties we
know, of how things behave in
the Newtonian world are not
necessarily valid at atomic
dimensions.
This is very important stuff.
Anyway, so what I did is I went
through the paper and
I've reduced the content of
the paper to these things
called postulates.
So Rutherford's atom
is correct.
That's the first thing.
Classical electromagnetic theory
not applicable to the
orbiting electron.
And you're going to get-- the
PDF and all this is going to
be posted, so don't feel like
you have to be a super
stenographer here.
Newtonian mechanics
is applicable to
the orbiting electron.
So you can see, wait a minute
it's sort of like cafeteria
physics here.
Electrodynamics doesn't
apply, Newtonian
mechanics does apply.
And the answer is, yeah.
That's what we're going
to do here.
We'll build a model and we're
going to try these ideas out.
And if they're crazy,
how are we going to
know they're crazy?
Because there's going to
be data that refute.
But if we get data that supports
all this, then
there's only one conclusion.
This thing makes sense
up to a point.
The energy of the electron is
conserved in the system.
It's bond is kinetic
plus potential.
The quantization through
angular momentum.
And lastly, the Planck-Einstein
relation
applying to electron
transition.
So now I'm going to take all
this and I'm going to write
out the model for you.
Now, I don't want you
to say, oh, he's
going to derive something.
Do we have to know
derivations?
This is the only time
I'm going to derive
something for you.
The reason is, it teaches
the model.
It teaches how the
model is based on
assumptions and so on.
But I don't expect you to
memorize things because that's
not the way things work.
So let's go starting with
this point here.
This point here is
Bohr model atom.
So it's Bohr's representation
of the Rutherford model.
We can call it a nuclear model
or a planetary model.
Because you've got orbiting
electrons.
Now, first important point.
The Bohr model is the
simplest model.
It works for a one
electron system.
So he has a single electron.
Planetary model, single
electron.
And this orbits the
positive nucleus.
So you might say, one electron,
well, what's that mean?
Well, obviously it means
atomic hydrogen.
But it could mean helium plus.
That's a one electron system.
It could mean lithium 2 plus.
It could mean roentgenium
110 plus.
That's a one electron system.
And this is all gas.
Gas phase.
No solids here.
So it's an isolated nucleus with
one electron around it.
That's how we're
going to begin.
And here's what it looks like.
I'm going to put the nucleus,
first of all not to scale,
because we're not going
to draw 10,000 to 1.
Over here is the nucleus
with z positive charge.
And then out here is the
electron in orbit.
This is the lone electron
in orbit.
And this distance is r.
The distance from the nucleus.
You're going to say, well,
is that from the
outside or the inside?
It's 10,000 to 1; it
doesn't matter.
Forget about it.
So now let's use this concept.
We're going to say it's a
conservative system and so the
energy of the system is
simply going to be the
energy of the electron.
You might say, well, why
don't you consider the
energy of the nucleus?
Because the nucleus is,
relatively speaking,
stationary.
To use Rutherford's colorful
language, he says when an
elephant has fleas, it's the
fleas that do the jumping.
So you don't care about
that energy of the
nucleus in this case.
So the energy of the
electron is the
kinetic plus the potential.
So the kinetic energy, we're
saying it's 1/2 mv squared
because it's Newtonian
mechanics apply.
See number 3.
So that's 1/2 mv squared,
where v is the velocity.
So that's the kinetic,
and then what's
the potential energy?
The potential energy here
is electrostatic.
Because that's the energy that's
stored here is due to
the Coulombic forces
between them.
So that's going to be q1,
q2 over 4 pi epsilon
0 divided by r.
So what I'm going to do here, we
have to just for convention
I'm going to always choose that
q1 in my derivation, q1
will be the charge on the
nucleus. so q1 will equal z,
which is the proton
number here, times
the elementary charge.
Remember e is the elementary
charge.
It's not the charge
on the electron.
So sometimes I use the
word e with a minus
sign, meaning the electron.
But this is e meaning the
elementary charge.
z times e and then q2, which is
the charge on the electron,
is minus the elementary
charge e.
So we're always going to
have minus e out here.
What varies is z.
And so we're going to make
some substitutions.
So this is going to be what?
It's going to be 1/2 mass of the
electron times velocity of
the electron squared.
And now q1 is ze and
q2 is minus z, so
that's minus ze squared.
And then that'll be over
4 pi epsilon 0 r.
And I'm going to call this
thing equation 1.
And by the way you can find
all of this information by
looking at your table
of constants.
So see, epsilon 0
sitting here.
Permittivity of vacuum.
There it is, 8.85 times 10 to
the minus 12 farads per meter.
Elementary charge 1.6 times 10
to the minus 19 Coulombs.
Electron mass, 9.1 times 10 to
the minus 31 kilograms. And
what's this 4 pi epsilon
0 doing here?
Well we know this is going
to give us joules.
And this is going to
give us joules.
And the epsilon 0 is the
factor that renders
electrostatic units on
to the same plane
as mechanical units.
If I plug in-- this is going to
be Coulombs, it's Coulombs
squared, and this is going to be
meters, and now this things
is farads per meter.
And I got farads per meter
times meters divided by
Coulombs squared.
I don't care.
This, with impunity is joules.
Because this is an
energy unit.
And this is Systeme
Internationale.
And this is kilograms times
meters per second, meters per
second and how many apples
in a bushel and--
forget it!
Put this in kilograms. Put this
in in meters per second.
With impunity, it's in joules.
So that's what that
thing does there.
Alright.
Good.
So let's keep going.
Postulate 3.
Newtonian mechanics applies
to orbiting electrons.
So orbiting electron, it's
in a stationary orbit.
So that's the thing.
So postulate 3 implies that the
sum of the forces acting
on the electron must be 0.
This is a force balance,
right?
If the forces are out of
balance, the electrons are
either going to move closer to
the nucleus or move farther
from the nucleus.
So that's equal to, again--
it's a sum of a dynamic force
and a Coulombic force, or
electrostatic.
Here I just noticed a
nice parity here.
So these are technical terms,
but we can give them human
terms. So the dynamic force,
there's a Newtonian force,
this is a Newtonian force and
this is a Coulombic force,
after the two people that are
associated with the ideas.
Charges interaction
are Coulombic,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
So now lets substitute in.
So we know that if you've got
something orbiting, something
tethered, then the dynamic force
on that, that pulls the
object away on a tether
is mv squared over r.
And the electrostatic is q1 q2
over 4 pi epsilon 0 r squared.
Force goes as 1 over
r squared.
Energy goes as 1 over r.
How do you know?
Well, one way to think about it
is, you know energy is the
result of a force moving
through a distance.
You say, I'm working really
hard, and I say I don't see
any force moving through
a distance.
That's a joke.
So here's energy.
So force.
So if this is 1 over r squared,
the integral of 1
over r squared is
minus 1 over r.
If you get these backwards, you
integrate 1 over r, you're
going to get natural log of
r, which makes no sense.
That's one way.
Or the other way is, you
can just remember.
So anyways we're going to
plug into those values.
And what do we get?
What we get there is this.
We get mv squared over r.
q1 is z times e.
q2 is minus z.
So it's minus ze squared over
4 pi epsilon 0 r squared.
And I'm going to call
this equation 2.
So now we keep going.
Next one, energy quantized
through its angular momentum.
This is really critical.
This is the major breakthrough
by Bohr.
Now what do we mean
by quantization?
I told you that in 1909,
Millikan had figured out that
electrical charge
is quantized.
Now quantization had already
been annunciated by
Max Planck in 1909.
You see, the classical theory
of radiation gave this
prediction for intensity as
a function of wavelength.
They called this the
explosion, the
collapse of the theory.
As you go to low wavelength,
the intensity
goes without abatement.
But these are the spectra
that were measured.
Depending on the temperature
of the gas, you get this
distribution.
So how to get the distribution
to turn around at lower values
of wavelength?
And in order to do that, Planck
suggested that light is
composed of energy packets,
or quanta.
That light is a stream of
individual energy bits.
And the elementary unit of
electromagnetic radiation is
the photon.
And you can say, well I don't
understand, where
goes he get that from?
That's not the way to
think about it.
Say, if you make
this assumption
you get these curves.
And then figure out
what it means.
You can't make everything
anthropomorphic.
If this were the case, and
furthermore if the energy of
one of these quanta was related
to its frequency--
and wavelength and frequency
are inversely related--
then the proportionality
constant is h, which we now
have designated the Planck
constant in honor of Planck,
then you get this.
People grew to accept it.
1900, he gets a Nobel
Prize for it.
La de da!
But who knows what
light is anyways.
It has no mass, it's
kind of mysterious.
1900, the whole concept of
action at a distance was
strange to people.
The notion that something could
affect you, from me,
without physical contact,
this was a new idea.
We take it for granted,
but this was very new.
So it's kind of mysterious,
they said, OK, he's a
physicist, who knows?
And it worked!
But it's light.
Now what Bohr is going to say
is the electron moving in
orbit, he says, I'm going to
apply the same concept of
quantization to the electron
moving in orbit.
Well, that's different.
And using this value he gives
us mvr, which is the angular
momentum is quantized
n h over 2 pi.
h is the Planck Constant
and n is an integer.
1, 2 3 4, et cetera.
So this is the quantum condition
and this will be
equation 3.
And I have three equations and
three unknowns, and what I'm
going to do next day is come
back and show you the solution
of the equations and how they
give us a set of equations
that allow us to compare
with data.
So let's jump to the thing.
And by the way the Planck
constant is there.
Now Niels Bohr eventually
won the Nobel Prize.
He was widely revered.
He achieved the stature on
a par with Einstein.
If you go to Denmark, it's still
not part of the European
Union, you can still get the 500
Kroner note if you change
a 100-dollar bill there.
And there's Niels Bohr
with this pipe.
And you can see the concept
of things rotating
around it an so on.
There's a young Niels Bohr.
This is Bohr with Werner
Heisenberg.
Heisenberg was a post-doc who
worked with Bohr in 1925 and
annunciated the Uncertainty
Principle, which we will study
a few lectures from now.
This is a chemical conference
sponsored by
chemical company Solvay.
Brussels 1930, there's
Bohr and Einstein.
They loved hats.
This is the Hamburg,
this is Borsalino.
Here's Bohr mixing it
up with royalty.
This is a young Queen Elizabeth
of England.
There's Prince Phillip.
This is the royalty
Danish family.
Bohr loved music and here
is with Louis Armstrong
undoubtedly talking about the
resonant structures within the
tube here and how to
get the various
harmonics and overtones.
Now last thing, a little
bit about hydrogen.
We've been studying hydrogen
here, the one electron atom.
But there are isotopes
of hydrogen.
The original was discovered
by Henry Cavendish.
There is one form of hydrogen
that has a neutron in addition
to the proton.
That's the deuterium, from
which we can get
heavy water, D2O.
This was discovered here
in New York at Columbia
University by Harold Urey.
And then lastly, there's a
second isotope of hydrogen
that consists of two neutrons
and a proton.
That's tritium and it was
discovered at the Cavendish
lab by Ernest Rutherford.
He was active right
up to his death.
In fact, it is argued that
Rutherford did his best work
after he got the Nobel Prize.
Your book is showing this.
It's nice to follow.
We started with Dalton and now
we're here and then later, in
another week or so, we'll
be down here.
And here's the sort of the
intellectual road map that
takes you to modern
atomic theory.
So with that I'll dismiss
the class and
we'll see you on Wednesday.